oh it's been driving you crazy we've
been talking about we didn't know when
it was going to happen well now we have
the dates that both Tropicana and I-15
are going to be completely closed next
month
Tropicana will be closed between D
Martin and New York New York from
January 22nd until January 30th the I-15
will be shut down between Flamingo and
Russell from 10 pm January 27th until 5
a.m January 30th the Nevada Department
of transportation's Justin Hopkins it's
not just Lane restrictions and it's not
just a traffic headache it is actually
full stop 24 7 closures of Tropicana for
eight days and of I-15 for three full
days MDOT Project Director Lynette
Russell once we close Tropicana on the
22nd it is very much about removals
so when she talks about removals they're
talking about removing the start of the
flyover ramp from the south 15 the one
that goes over to eastbound drop we're
going to have a lot more about this as
the date gets closer but this thing's
not being called drop a can of for
nothing and I was hoping that you'll
consider downloading the I-15 Drop app
you'll have everything you'll need to
know at your fingertips buckle up drive
carefully please put down that phone and
you can join the driving a crazy
conversation at traffic 8 at
8newsnow.com